how would you protect yourself and the
ones you love from the terror just
outside the dead how will you go by it's
gonna taste like rotting flesh welcome
thank you glad to be here so if anybody
you know a half state of decay pastime
and I really really recommend playing
the first one I'm back combat I just did
it recently but just can you just tell
us really quick what's it all about
yeah state of decay is it's all about
your own survival fantasy you know we
wanted to make a game that captured that
part of the zombie genre that was you
and your friends sitting around at the
pub after a good zombie flick and kind
of talking about your own personal
survival plans and so the games built
around that would give you the tools to
go tell your own survival story and see
how you do I love post-apocalyptic
stories right so tell me how did we get
into the into this mess how did we get
into the apocalypse and stay at Decatur
well that's something you have to find
out as a player we revealed a couple of
hints along the way and the original and
the sequel will be revealing a lot more
but still not exactly clear what
happened or how it happened and that's
something for the players to figure out
fair enough so when you were developing
the game like what did you get the guys
inspired by well you know at the time we
were thing we've been thinking about
this game for I mean more than a decade
and you know at the time there was this
kind of really good crop of re-emergence
of zombie movies there was the 28 days
later or 28 weeks later and then even
movies like zombie land and Shaun of the
Dead that brought a little bit of humor
to it and what what really became
apparent to all of us who were working
on this was that you know the zombie
genre was not about going around and
shooting and killing zombies it's about
it's about the people the connections of
the people who are surviving how they
work together
you know even like a movie like
Zombieland that's really a car buddy
movie right you know and so there's just
all this expressiveness in it and we
wanted to capture that that width and
breadth of the genre and not just the
how do you kill zombies so will we maybe
see a Twinkie well Twinkie is a
trademarked name and probably not but
you will definitely find Easter eggs
hidden throughout the game that call
back to some of the great moments from
from the zombie genre through some of
the new features and state of decay to
that you know maybe state of decay fans
will be excited to get our hands on our
primary goal was to really take what
worked in the first one and just double
down on it we came up with a really
unique formula the kind of third person
action married with the really deep RPG
progression mechanics for your
characters the base building and then
put that all in a simulated open-world
and that that formula really resonated
and really did well and so what we
wanted to do was just take that deep in
each of those systems and and really
just deepen the survival fantasy but in
addition all that we added the number
one fan requested feature which was
cooperative multiplayer so instated okay
- you're finally gonna be able to play
with your friends which is something
we've been looking forward to for a long
time one of the things I love the way
state to kata also caused me a lot of
pain as well was perma death are you
bringing that back and that's core to
the experience absolutely you know there
is no sense of threat there is no sense
of consequences for your actions if
there's not death in the game it's it's
part it's hard to imagine making a
zombie game that doesn't really have a
permadeath but you know the important
thing for us is that if you die in the
game you can always look at it and say
if only I had done this differently or
that differently right we never want you
to think the game just arbitrarily
decided it was time for you to die or or
you know kind of cheesed it right it has
to be because of something you did and
that's the contract we make with the
players so really this fan feedback
going back to the coop and I think about
safety k1 like what I have to do
managing community you have to build my
base like I have to go into the missions
how does it look on coop so what we
wanted to do is make coop really simple
we don't want a whole lot of like set up
your party mechanics and invitations and
joins what you do is you can
always just jump into your friends game
it's drop and drop out multiplayer but
we also have this really cool mechanic
where when you're playing the game you
can register to say I'm willing to help
people and then somebody else if they're
playing whether they're your friend or
not if they get in trouble they can
shoot a flare gun and you get a beacon
it says hey someone's in trouble and you
can hit that little Xbox button and you
jump right in and you're there to help
them out so it really gives it a feeling
of like a community helping community
which is really the heart and soul of
the game stated ak2 is a game of humans
working together to overcome the
apocalypse and the multiplayer mechanics
really support that well to be able to
get our hands on the game yes spring
2018 we can't wait thank you very much
yes thank you so much for coming in
right now it's time for another
brand-new trailer let's take a